all right welcome back to the show hey
there's going to be hockey this season
the pandemic
has changed all sorts of things but for
hockey fans the nhl camps
are opening and teams are getting ready
for a shortened season
now for the vegas gold knights camp
begins tomorrow with their season opener
coming up on
the 14th at home against the anaheim
ducks there will be no fans early on but
maybe as the season rolls along so who
knows well the knights go into the
season as one of the favorites to win
the stanley cup general manager kelly
mccrimmon
spoke to the media today and here's his
assessment as the knights get ready to
roll into camp uh excited uh
about camp beginning tomorrow we i know
did media 10 days ago
and uh we're anxious to get on the ice
tomorrow
today the flight of the players had uh
their medicals their fitness testing
the different uh things with uh photos
video shots that type of thing
uh really uh impressed by the fitness
level of our team
and the commitment that's been shown by
our players particularly over the last
five weeks coming out of
thanksgiving weekend you can tell that
players are excited about the season
and are doing everything possible to be
prepared and ready to have a good start
to the year
when we did media last time it was uh i
believe hours before the schedule
was made available to the media as i
suggested that morning
it's uh or that day it's unique and that
it's
uh full of uh double headers the entire
year
uh it's against the same seven teams all
year i mentioned
last time that we uh spoke how unique i
thought that was going to be and in fact
i'm not so sure that isn't the more
unique
uh aspect of the schedule is the fact
that you're playing eight uh
eight games against each of the seven
teams and that you're playing only
uh seven teams so it's uh it's gonna be
a sprint where you know effectively
beginning in the second half of the
season right now in a lot of respects so
there's going to be a lot of hockey
and it's important to be to be ready to
be prepared and that's what training
camp
will do for our team so i know uh the
coaches are anxious to get the players
on the ice tomorrow with uh with our on
ice sessions
uh and uh no different than yourselves
we're all excited to
uh to begin and watch our team our
intention is
uh is to have an american league team
this year i think the framework is in
place i
uh spoke last time about a call that we
had on december the 30th
which uh uh you know points to
an american league season all right so
once again
hockey back in las vegas getting set
still hit on game on